if I'm if I'm marketing a film I'm  spending nine as you're making the film  I'm storytelling I'm making animated  gifts every day on tumblr around your  film the stuff that you may even edit  out and I'm storytelling on these  platforms daily just giving out stuff  I'm doing a spreecast or a Ustream or a  Google hangout with the actors or  doctors or whoever you have in a film  months before the film comes out you  know how to sell a book sell it for nine  months before it comes out and then it  actually sells not okay my books out now  it's time to sell games over you don't  enough time so same thing with a film  for as long as you're fit the future of  film marketing is as you're filming it  your storytelling on these platforms and  then when the film comes out you've  actually built a community and you come  out and say buy the tickets